foreign
for the Press preview our first look at
Monday's front pages and tonight we'll
be having a look at the headlines with
the former conservative special advisor
Anita votech and a political editor for
HuffPost UK Kevin Schofield uh great to
see you we'll speak in a moment once
we've had a look at those front pages
beginning with the Metro leading with
the home secretaries speeding fine Rao
suela in fast Chance Saloon and pressure
on pm to launch inquiry into braverman's
speeding rail reads in front of the
Guardian as they too look at claims that
swella bravaman broke the ministerial
code
is the front of tomorrow's daily Express
claiming an exclusive its headline
Europe turns a blind eye to let migrants
reach UK
NHS apt to let patients book Private
health care reach the front of the times
as it looks at plans to cut waiting
lists
let's show the front of the Daily Mail
it's analyzing a new report that states
drug driving has become more prevalent
than drink driving
the Ft reports that China slaps a ban on
U.S chip maker after G7 rebuke ramps up
tensions
and the star predicts hot weather it's
baked Britain temperatures in the 20s
and tonight we are joined by Anita
botang and Kevin Schofield so lots to
talk about uh this evening let's start
shall we Anita uh with the front of the
Guardian uh most of the front pages
um are covering this in some form uh
this row about sowella bravaman's
speeding uh fine and uh tonight we've
learned that Richie soon at just before
he boarded the plane from Japan to come
back to the UK he said he is going to
meet with his ethics advisor
yes um so this is the uh the only
political story in town
um in terms of all the personalities and
the classic kind of Sunday story and um
The Guardian writes that there is going
to be potentially the Prime Minister as
you say looking into this story
um or so the reports are and they've
been around since probably about the
afternoon yesterday that's well a
problem and I should be clear it it
seems that when she was speeding she was
off of the option to pay a fine or to go
on a speed awareness course now there's
no indication that she sought to avoid
playing the fine all together
um by by sort of Nefarious means but
basically she tried to get this speed
awareness course done in a different way
I.E privately one to one and there's
some indication that she asked civil
servants to look into that matter for
her as well as asking one of her
political special advisors so that's
where the question has come over whether
she may have reached a ministerial code
and that's the thing that the Prime
Minister may or may not be under
pressure to look into Kevin uh The
sowella bravaman Rao let's just have a
look at the front of the Metro their
headline swell it in fast Chance Saloon
Anita was making the point that actually
what the issue is here in terms of the
ministerial code is if she was asking
for advice on a personal matter to to
civil servants and advisors
yeah I mean I think the allegation
certainly is that as a bleach of the
ministerial codes
um as you said actually speak to Sir
Laura magnus's independent ethics
advisor tomorrow to have a chat about it
and work out whether a full-blown
inquiry is required both labor and the
lib Dems unsurprisingly say that there
should be an inquiry they see this
obviously as an opportunity uh to have a
go at the government and um yeah you
could tell this morning
um at Rich's United press conference uh
in Japan that he was irritated pretty
touchy and obviously didn't want to be
speaking about
um our controversy surrounding his Home
Secretary he wanted to be talking about
the G7 Summit itself so it's not great
it's not looking great for solarbrough
and I think it's safe to say that she's
on the naughty Step at the moment and it
just it just depends now whether it is
escalated uh by racism against a
full-blown inquiry and um yeah it's not
it's not great it's not a great look
um for the Home Secretary even if on the
face that it looks like you know a
relatively minor
um infraction that being said this
impression that it gives of maybe a
government Minister trying to act you
know as if they have special privileges
that other people Ordinary People don't
have then that's not a great look at all
you can see why voters would take a
pretty dim view of it yeah an Anita this
is the sort of a culmination of a series
of um events and difficulties for swella
bravman um of late plus of course the
fact that she's going to be facing home
office questions in the Commons as well
this week how safe is she do you think
I think we have to separate out these
two issues
um and this is not an issue so the last
time similar Brahman perhaps found
herself
um with questions over the ministerial
code was concerning a situation where
she seemed to have sent something to
someone that would normally you know not
um not be advisable let's put it that
way
um this seems to be that she sort of
asked a question and there isn't any
indication and I think it's really
important to be clear about this that
the option was presented to her as it
would be standardly presented to most
people if they are Court speeding to
either have the fine or have a speed
awareness course so there was no
suggestion that she was simply trying to
avoid a fine by having a speed awareness
course let's be very clear about that
um what she was doing was saying can I
take the course in a slightly different
way
um but this does feel quite different to
the other issues where she has run of a
foul should we say
um particularly the one around her
sending a piece a document and to
someone who was not um for instance a
civil servant or a or a minister
um and so this one it might be that it's
slightly more and to most people might
feel lower level
um because I think I've seen some
reports of people slightly struggling to
articulate where she might have reached
the ministerial code and I guess on
strict reading you could say that she
asked the Civil Service to do something
that might conflict with the instruction
that they should use public resources
efficiently it's not the most sort of
cut and dried situation
um but I can quite understand why labor
and the liberal Democrats are trying to
make as much of it as possible because
they know that on issues such as
immigration these are highly contentious
issues and they have been gunning for
swella for quite some time yeah and of
course the migration figures are going
to show that legal net migration at a
record hi Kevin in coming days
yeah we're expecting those figures to
come out on Thursday and they're
certainly not going to be great for the
government when the uh the last election
they promised to bring down net
migration at that time it was 226 000
we're looking now at possibly 800 000
even higher and now there's tension
inside the cabinet over
um what Cyril Braven would say is the
imperative of bringing down immigration
whereas the chancellor German Hunt is a
bit more pragmatic and saying well we
have to bear in mind the economic cost
of lowering immigration in terms of
economic growth so so yeah um it's going
to be an uncomfortable day certainly
tomorrow for our home office questions
and even more uncomfortable I would
suggest on Thursday when these um net
migration figures come out and then Tory
MPS in particular will be wanting to
know exactly what the government is
going to do to try and bring bring those
figures down yeah and let's stick with
migration uh front of the Daily Express
Anita quite a headline this Europe turns
Blind Eye to let migrants reach the UK
saying that Europe is getting rid in in
quotes of migrants by sending tens of
thousands to Britain this is calling to
a people Smuggler they've spoken to
yes um and this is according to a
people's Smuggler so we should
um better that in mind but there is
there is no doubt that every country in
Europe
um that is you know in in some way has a
porous border which is pretty much all
of them is suffering under the pressure
of the volume of migrants coming over
and that absolutely no country wants to
be the only you know
um uh vessel for all of the migrants
that are coming over on whether that's
on boats um over the channel or in any
any part of Europe and and certainly
like no country in Europe has figured
out a way to you know manage this
situation which is proving to be quite
overwhelming for significant numbers of
countries so it's certainly the case
that I imagine
um there's a bit of hot potato around um
migrants and certainly one of the
challenges that the UK has like many
other countries is getting returns
agreements um with countries so there
are some countries that are are you know
broadly safe and all for instance where
someone's um claim to Asylum might be
rejected and at the moment one of the
challenges is getting agreements that
those people can be sent back um to the
country from whence they came so there
is a lot of fraught politics in the
migrant situation in Europe because no
country has managed to work out how to
successfully deal with the volumes of
people that are coming over Kevin
yeah I mean I think and it's pointer
she's absolutely right it's a people
Smuggler who's making these allegations
so you have to I guess take it with a
little bit of a pinch of salt but
there's no doubt that politically it is
uh I'm a Hot Topic and the government uh
resistance is focusing primarily on
illegal immigration stopping the
stopping the boats as one of these five
promises uh that he made it at the start
of the year and he will be judged on his
success or otherwise on achieving that
that pledge
um and it's and it's really difficult
you know the boats are still coming
um and as you see the figures on
Thursday albeit is about legal migration
they're heading in the wrong direction
as far as the government's concerned as
well so
um you know the next election is only
less than 18 months away now probably
um it will be with us before we know it
and unless this is sunak and the
government start to prove that they're
making progress on these promises that
they've made both him personally and the
conservatives at the last election then
I think they're in for a pretty tough
time yeah let's talk about something
else that's going to be a a huge point
of contention in the run-up to any
general election the NHS and how we're
going to solve all the issues that it's
facing front of the times Anita and
we're noticed armor tomorrow is going to
make a big speech about Labor's plans
for the NHS but this is a government
idea and any the NHS app will allow
patients to choose treatment in private
hospitals in a bid to cut waiting lists
yes and and the times has the latest
figures there of the um waiting list
currently at
7.33 million which is an astonishing
number
um and it's really interesting the
government has been exploring some of
these Innovative policies so this one
would allow you to book
um you know use uh for instance a
private health care or hospital or
referral
um somewhere in your area as opposed to
having to wait for the NHS and that's
something that has been used in the past
not in the form of apps but the private
sector has been used to get down waiting
lists memorably
um under Tony Blair so this is something
that has been done before
um and and private providers are a part
of the NHS insofar as you can often I
personally have gotten referrals to
um to private hospitals and via the NHS
and it seems to me to be a practical way
um to help tackle the wait list and um
which you see like also and it didn't
get much coverage announced that they
were going to kind of have pharmacies do
and play a much bigger role
um and make people and your and your
viewers that travel to France will know
that for instance pharmacies play a much
larger role in the NHS and are often the
people that you would go to if you had a
cold or a sore throat and normalizing
some of that could also help and serve
to take pressure off the NHS so I think
two very good Innovations okay we'll get
your thoughts on that one Kevin in the
next hour because I just want to ask you
about Ukraine it's on the front of the
Guardian cave denying Russia has control
of Batman the the Kremlin saying they do
have either way they almost have
complete control don't they and what's
left of it it's it's a city in Ruins
absolutely as I mean this battle has
been going on now for a very long time
as soon as a very important both
psychologically and strategically um the
Russians have been trying to take back
uh as I say for quite some time Ukraine
has managed to fend them off but it
looks as though the Russians have pretty
much taken over now obviously Vlad
vladius has been in Japan at the G7 and
today was denying that was the case you
can obviously understand why he would
say that but
um yeah it's not looking great for the
ukrainians there however we're still to
um see the counter-offensive which we're
expecting in the coming months from from
Ukraine so there's sadly there's no
Prospect of the War ending anytime soon
and obviously as a seasoninski was in
Japan over the last few days trying to
drum up more and Global support for the
Ukrainian war effort so uh so yeah it
seems as though it was relatively
successful obviously the UK announced
last week as well for their support and
for Ukraine um but you know this as I
say this this conflict unfortunately and
there is no end in sight